the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay here we go
all set and two topics for today one is
to go back to Professor SRA's lecture
that was last Friday and he promised a
theorem and proof and this morning he
sent it to me so it's the convergence
it's proving the convergence of
stochastic gradient descent and really
what's important maybe and useful is not
so much the details of the proof which
I'm just learning but the assumptions
you know what's the logic here what do
you have to assume about the gradient to
and about the algorithm to get the
answer and but now I actually look back
at the video of his lecture and it was
excellent and as I look at it there were
a couple of things later in the lecture
that I thought would make good projects
so I don't know if anybody is still open
to what to do on a project but here here
are my two ideas and and if you if
you've already finished your project
well get an A+ by considering one of
these so you remember and this will
remind you of the of the lecture which
is a good thing so you remember that
question one was whether in the
stochastic part do you after you've
sampled
one or some mini batch but let's just
say one
of the loss functions coming from one
sample you remember the whole point is
that if we do all zillions samples at
every iteration we're really really slow
so the stochastic idea is to randomly
pick one or a mini batch of the samples
and and just reduce their loss just deal
with their the loss say the square loss
or later we'll see cross-entropy loss
but whatever the cost is just do a few
or one and then the question was after
you've done that one you put it back in
the pot and every time you sample over
the whole collection but that's
expensive or do you just make a list of
random list of random order of all the
samples and go through them which is
then without replacement which is sort
of semi illegal that is the the the
logic in in the randomization asks you
to replace every time but nobody does it
wait costs a lot probably not worth it
so the project would be suppose you take
a thousand or say just a hundred hundred
random numbers say say you use MATLAB
random just the command R and so you get
numbers whose averages a half from R and
they're between 0 & 1 ok so we know what
the average is so let's compute it two
ways one is by not replacing and that's
the interesting one do you so so to take
a hundred samples well I guess we know
that after we've got through the full
hundred we're gonna get exactly the
right now
but anyway there my question would be
how much difference do you see in in the
eventual approach so the law of large
numbers I guess would tell us we get a
average of 1/2 for these numbers with
uniform distribution between 0 and 1
should I be writing anything here
maybe I should okay so I'm this is
project one you pick numbers a K which
is R and from R and so uniformly on 0 1
0 0 1 and then I my question is what
about convergence to the the final the
average is 1/2
it says maybe too simple an example but
could we see what happens for the
convergence of the average as you either
do replacements or don't do replacements
and then in fact I would like to see a
figure that looks like those in his
lecture t remember he started it
somewhere start and then here's the
finish but you remember that stochastic
gradient descent was kind of a pretty
effective at the beginning well the
beginning those might be a hundred
iterations each one Epoque one one run
through the full number but then when it
got to here got closer it started
oscillating you remember he identified
the region of confusion around the thing
well my suggestion is just I think those
videos should be accessible to you on
are they on stellar yeah so I'd love to
see that behavior in some some good
examples of that behavior and some
pictures to use so that would be one
idea with Andres oh yeah that's also
idea to idea to is the is the good start
and then the bad finish for a stochastic
gradient descent and of course the magic
words in even without this the magic
words and computations is early stopping
we we don't over fit so we wanted to
stop early anyway and early stopping
just as like a good idea
for if that's what if that's what the
approach to the to the X star that
you're looking for the this would be the
place where the this is where that's X
star where we're grad F and X star is
near oh that's that's the minimum point
that's Arg men are men exactly what
we're looking for and we don't find it
very well
but we get close to it fast okay two
ideas on project so just so maybe I'll
go to the main topic of today the topic
I promised the idea of back propagation
to compute this is all to compute
grad F the gradient all the derivatives
this is this is the DF DX 1 to DF DX M
maybe I'll say where I have M M features
for for is for the sample okay so that's
back propagation and that's the thing
whose discovery or rediscovery put
neural nets on the map without that's
the key calculation of course to find
the gradient in the steepest descent
algorithm every step needs a gradient
and if you can't compute it quickly
you're you're in bad shape so but you
can compute it quickly by this automatic
differentiation in Reverse mode which is
otherwise known those I don't think that
people maybe Hinton was the first was
the leader in in the in developing deep
neural nets deep learning and he
realized so I give him big credit for
that back propagation would work and
would give him fast gradients but it
actually had been studied before under
the name ad automatic differentiation so
merit just tell you that idea
some of you may know it may know about
it may know more than I and might know
good a good website to see this
description
there'll be of course a section of the
book of the notes already you you
already have it section this is
in 7.2 so this is the chapter on deep
learning and the first section was about
the structure of f of X and you remember
the key point about the structure of f
of X is that it would I start with X and
apply some function f1 of X and to that
I apply some function f2 of X and to
that I apply some function of F 3 F 3 of
F 2 of F 1 of X and that's the thing
whose derivative I need so I'll just
take ordinary derivative you know well
partial derivatives really because I
yeah I better say partial derivatives so
suppose X is a pair XY example so so
here let me show you by example so
suppose f of X is let me take a simple
example X cubed times X plus 2y okay so
I want to think of that function the way
anybody would as being built as the
product of two functions so there's a
product rule to get into the derivative
and then we need the derivatives of each
piece so there's a power rule and a
linear and a linear combination rule so
it's got a few of the rules that we use
and point is to think about the
computation of f of X and the
computation of DF DX and the computation
of DFT Y those are the derivatives that
we need this is the function we need and
how to do those computations quickly
okay so and this is section 7.2 which I
which benefited a lot from
a blog I'm not a blog reader or a blog
writer but somehow I found this blog so
let me put its Christopher
Olaf is his name and he's really writes
to clear things so he he he contributes
he works for one of the big companies
and does you know the deeper research
but he's also a really good expose etre
and the the website that he now uses is
called distill dot something but I think
maybe this blog was earlier before the
start of distill but it might be loaded
onto distill anyway that's that's where
I got this simple description of
backpropagation let's just do calculus
for first of all if I just have a
function of maybe even one variable
what's the derivative what is DF DX here
just to realize just to remember what is
it
what calculation we have to do so DF DX
this is with n equal one one variable so
I'll I use ordinary derivative and not
partial derivative but this is then what
I that's what really has to be done but
just what's the derivative of that of a
chain of functions well of course the
chain rule so the chair what does the
chain rule say I differentiate f3 I
don't know what do I well well I put
that it's differentiated with respect to
f3 DF 3 d f2 is that what I should put
ok
and where do I evaluate that derivative
so so so yeah I don't evaluate it at X
right I'm different effective F - so do
I evaluate it at F to of F 1 of X this
is where the chain rule gets a little
cheney okay then we know that DF 2 DF 1
and again that's now evaluated at F 1 of
X and then the final factor is DF 1 be X
evaluated at X that's somehow what we
have to do and that's just for an
ordinary one variable function and I
have here a two variable function and
deep learning has a million variable
function so let's I think we won't go to
a million but two we can manage so let's
let's let's compute those let's compute
the function first of all compute F so
I'm given X equal say 2 and y equals say
3 and what do I'm gonna create a
computational graph so this is just to
draw so I'm actually going to draw the
computational graph
to compute for for 4f and then it'll be
a variation of that graph to find the
derivatives but so let's just start with
the graph first of all for the function
because we're gonna need that so again
it's X cubed but so okay I write that
function again X cubed times X plus 2y
so I think we're going to the first step
will be to find X plus X cubed that
factor which will be 8 and we have to
find the other factor X plus 2y so then
I'm going to that uses Y and X so these
are its a directed graph going forward
with this computation so X plus 2 y
equals whatever it is two and six oh
eight again not brilliant
what shall I change here make it 3 y 3y
just to get a different number here so
now X is 2 y is 3 I get 11 that's a good
number
ok so far so good and now the next step
on this graph will be to I have a
product of those so that will go to the
product F equals 8 times 1188
ok so we've got the answer 88 would you
which mess normally I wouldn't take that
much of a book to compute F
I would have said 2 cubed times 2 plus 3
times 3 and I'd have simplified that to
8 times 11 and I would have got 88 so if
we were just writing normally that would
do it but this is the picture of the
computational graph ok good good good
now it's the derivatives two derivatives
to find the F DX in the f dy suppose we
go forward first
my point is going to be or the great
point is that backward is better reverse
mode is better but we don't know what
that means until we've gone forward so
let me go forward so now I'm gonna go
forward
[Applause]
so what do we what let's do the F DX ok
everybody's up for DF DX the partial
derivative spec 2x so here we have X
equal 2 and y equals 3
okay and then I've got to figure I take
the derivative of that step the first
step was X 2x cubed so I need the
derivative the whole point of ad is that
the computation every computation of a
derivative breaks down like this and a
very simple pieces and the derivatives
of those simple pieces are also simple
pieces so the whole point is to break
the to replace appropriately the there
was those intermediate steps with
derivatives so so as to compute the X
derivative so so I have to use the fact
that the derivative of x cubed with
respect to X oh I better do partial
derivative partial grooves of X cubed
spiked 2x or 3x squared so now I'll I'm
sorry up put maybe a formula and then a
number so that gives that gives 3 times
4 12 and the derivative of x cubed with
respect to Y gives 0 right and then the
derivative so I'm doing the X derivative
so the derivative of Y with respect to X
is you get to tell me if I'm if I'm
computing partial derivatives is 0 is 0
Y and X are independent and that's this
is the reason in my view that the
forward method is is wasteful because
I'm gonna have to do another
graph for the y derivative in other
words tracking the tracking the x
derivatives a whole lot of stuff never
got off the ground so it never should
have looked at it so anyway but I do
need
I'll have this X plus 3y so maybe I
don't know whether to erase that I think
I will just because I don't know what to
do with it there yeah so now now let me
take the ones that I really need is
derivative with respect to X of x plus
3y which is 1 and so that gives me the
answer 1 for any X actually okay and now
what
oh I yeah I'm really I don't need these
the this is a waste of time isn't it
is it only X derivatives I want anyway
let's just keep going
you can see this takes a little
organization and I'm not practiced with
it so what am I going to do I'm looking
for the X derivative of I've got to use
a product rule now I found the X
derivative of that factor was 12 the X
derivative of this factor is 1 and now
the X derivative of the product so so
now I'm gonna do a somehow product rule
the the X derivative of this product I
sort of given these two terms a name
let let me call let me call that first
term X cube and the second term
x + 3 1 : f so I'll call that the two
the two terms CNS so I now need to get I
now need to get so that's the CD s this
is DC DX right this is DC DX and this
one is d s DX and the CD why do I need
to know that I'm sorry I'm this
computational graph has thrown me but
now now I want to use the product rule
and I'm taking X derivatives right so I
should have computed C and s ah yes I
see I've got a you need those in the
product rule so I should have computed
see as being 8 + s as being 5 that right
2 + 3 11 yeah I needed the eight in the
oh what's up I've just been running
along here without getting myself in the
whole picture yeah 8 and 11 is right but
now I'm looking for the derivatives
right so I don't multiply those that's
not the product rule so the product rule
is what s times so so this product rule
I should I have to do this combination
of this is now the product rule for the
derivative of C times s so I want C D s
DX + s DC DX I think I'm on track now
and now I want to put in numbers
so C is 8 the SDX have we computed D s
DX yes the s DX is 1 and now s itself is
computed as 11 and DC DX we computed as
12 I I don't dare look have I am I am i
I don't think I'm gonna get oh no I
don't know what the answer yet sorry I'm
not trying to get 88 right you guys are
not helping you see I'm in trouble but
what I what I imagine here is that's 8
and that's 132 so I'm getting 140 ha is
there any possibility that that's the
right answer
for D for D F D X this is DF DX I
computed you by watching me struggle
here you're seeing the idea I every step
I take the derivative of each step so it
was a power step X cube so I had a 3x
squared and a some step so I had a 1
then I the next step was a
multiplication so I needed the product
rule for that I have these separate
numbers so I put them in and so it's a
the computational graph finished we only
needed two levels and we got 8 and 130
to 140 okay but we didn't get the FD why
yes and for that I'd need another need
to redo this again and I don't want to
do that I would rather do the reverse
mode and do them both at once that's the
point of the river
smooth it's very efficient it's very
efficient actually computing the
gradient after you've done the done the
work for the function computing first
derivatives you could compute n first
derivatives with about like four or five
times the cost not end times that that's
amazing to me
that is amazing that that I can compute
the gradient very efficiently by it by
the back prop so I have to you have to
show you the backwards way but so I'm
just yeah just I'm just going to follow
all the paths backwards so that I get
both DF DX and D F dy just by you see
the idea is to take the derivative of
each step each small step that's really
what we do in calculus you know if you
think about the start of a calculus
course what do you what derivatives do
we actually know do we actually use X F
at X plus Delta X minus F do we what
derivatives do we grind out we do the
derivatives of X to the N every calculus
book starts with x squared and and and
finds a derivative X to the n then you
do sine X and plus X then what others
are there anymore
even e to the X good e to the X and it's
the inverse function log in freshman
calculus you always write Ln just to be
out of date okay and now that may be the
list is it and then the chain rule there
are there others that you actually do a
computation of actually e to the X is
defined by the property that its
derivative is e to the X and then you
discover what log X has to be and sine X
you how do you do
of X plus Delta X will compare minus
sine of X how do you find the you know
the hard way once and for all way you
draw a little unit circle and and mess
with some some angles and you discover
that the derivative of the sine is the
cosine that's if you've defined the sign
from as a ratio of sides in a in a right
triangle of course you could define it
as an infinite series and then you would
be back to just using that okay so so
calculus does exactly what we're doing
here finds all derivatives by the chain
rule applied to a few ones that it has
has worked out in detail but tangent of
X we would use the quotient rule secant
of X we would use the quotient rule one
over cosine and the products we use the
product rule so really calculus tends to
seem fairly simple after when you look
back to see what actually you did and
then integration what is integral
calculus about more or less guessing the
answer right you you you have to
integrate f of X DX
and you have so really what you what you
have to do is sort of think okay what
had this derivative what function had
that derivative and mess around and get
it so that's really it's uh it's it's a
freshman course I guess okay so where am
I
backward right that's the thing still to
do how does the backward system work
okay I'll try it try my best
okay so here's the here's the big goal
back so reverse mode ad right and let me
make myself a little note a little
little notice to give you another
example where the order that you do the
computations makes a big difference I
mean and that's not obvious that it will
right there are many things in math that
you could do in either order and it it
seems like logically you've done the
same things so another another and
simpler example which shows how one way
could be fast away faster than another
way is when I'm multiplying two matrices
three matrices so I'm multiplying three
matrices a times B times C and the
question is do I do B C first and then
multiply by a or do I do a B first and
then multiply that by C and of course I
kept them in order in the order ABC but
the order of computations can be
different then you get the same you get
the right answer both ways but those can
be completely completely different one
can be a thousand times faster than the
other so that's just to show actually it
kind of connects to this and there is
also another so I'll I'll do that too
and there's also this so this is example
example two where this is meant to be
example one and example three would be
it leads to something called the adjoint
method in in in differential equations
or in in optimization in in computing in
computing optimum in maximizing - yeah
and that has the same they're really the
underlying reason it gives a speed up is
it makes the right choice in a product
of three things yeah so it'll be enough
to do example one an example - okay let
me go with the example one hour all
right this is now back propagation
finally we got to it okay so how do i
how do i well i look at my look at my
notes it's how I do it okay
so the notes this is section seven point
two does these computational graphs and
then here is reverse mode so it starts
over here with so I'm going to use the
chain rule so DF DF is one and then and
then I going going backwards - and I
have to use of course I have to I have
to take the derivatives I have to find
use the right rule so I have to use the
product rule and then soon I'll have to
use these power rule and linear rules so
of course no change there the change is
that by going backwards oh I did I don't
know if I completed that sentence that I
could find the hundred partial
derivatives if the function depended on
a hundred variables in about five times
the cost of one variable three three to
five times the cost of one so so that
you would expect a hundred a hundred
chain rules would cost a hundred times
but but you see we're reusing the pieces
in the chain and just having a larger
our chain is wider but it's not longer
and it's not repeated anyway so here I'm
gonna use whatever it is DF DC and DF
the s remembering that so what in my
yeah okay so so DF D is DC is s and the
FPS is C that was because because
because F started out as C times s it
was a product okay
then we've got to evaluate those now
I'll look again to see that I'm
hopefully writing down some of the
correct things okay so now I've what
I've written down next is the FTC is
five or no five on the on that example
what is it here the FTC is C is X cubed
so DF oh sorry
DF T yeah I want s I'm looking for s
here yep I'm looking for ass so I'm
looking for s and that's X plus three
why am I doing this well I I want in the
end to get the derivatives with respect
to X and why the whole gradient okay I
think we're started right the first
derivatives is to write C NS and then
let me leave these boxes open just to
get the picture then I'm going to do
then I'll need DC d X DC D Y D s DX
and DSD why I think that's right
write that here I had a product of CNS
so I needed to had two derivatives here
I have CNS each to differentiate so I
get to have an x and a y derivative x
and a y derivative and now it just it's
just a matter of putting in those
numbers and following the chain
backwards maybe I'm not going to put
those numbers in because I if I didn't
reach 140 you wouldn't believe in back
propagation and that would be like an
unhappy outcome so I'll leave you to put
them in maybe or the notes have a
separate example that you can see but do
you see the point that I'm going to find
all the in the end I'm going to find the
F DX and the f dy from the from the
chain all in from one chain and not not
not from a separate chain 4x and a
separate chain for y that's that's to me
that's the point of reverse mode it's a
little bit of magic but you see the
steps the ingredient and and some of you
know have seen this before and maybe
know a better exposition I found this
blog by Christopher Ola clear and these
very simple things you'll see are clear
in the notes but maybe another blog
makes it brings out other points to make
to make here it's not obvious maybe that
I could have a hundred variables and and
and do the calculation in four or five
times the cost for four or five times
being instead of a hundred
yeah but it's possible okay so can I
come close today with this one how could
those be different your computing the
same numbers the same AI j bj k SI que
eles and and doing this sums but it's
certainly is different so let's just do
that okay I'll do it here and then at
the right time and I guess it'll be
after professor Rao and on Friday and
Monday I'll come back to professors Fras
short proof of the convergence of a
stochastic gradient descent the whole
point is to show you what assumptions do
you need you need some assumptions on
the gradient some assumptions on the
step size and they've for a good proof
all the assumptions fit together and Don
outcomes the conclusion and the
conclusion would be how fast it
converges stochastic gradient descent so
there's some there's some s expected
things because it's stochastic we expect
some assumptions about the mean and the
variance to go into the into the proof
so you'll see that but maybe it's too
much for today so for today I'll just
come back to that I might even put it on
stellar and just close with this so
suppose a is M by n B is n by P and C is
P by Q okay
how many steps does it take to find a
times B times C the product of those
three matrices well if I go this way I
have to multiply a I have to do BC first
so BC costs how many operations to
multiply that times that n PQ nice
formula n PQ why is that well I could
say that the answer is is n by Q and
every number in there was an inner
product of a row and column of length P
so I have NQ inner products and each one
costs P multiply ads and then so now now
I have BC which will be now so it's so
now I have M by n then then I have M by
n which is the a times B by C which is
now n by Q that's BC this is ABC so and
this one costs what's the cost here M by
n n by Q by the same rule that'll be M
and Q good that's that's the first way a
times BC now the second way is a B times
C and let me write in again and by N and
by P P by Q so now I'm doing this first
so a B costs tell me again now what's
the rule for the cost of a matrix
multiplication MN p m and p
and then then I have I'm multiplying M
by P that's a B times P by Q that's C so
I have M P Q so I have that together
with that or that together with that
that sum those two or these two and
they're different and let's just let's
just recognize the most important
example suppose C is a column vector C
for a column vector so Q is one there's
only one column so if Q is 1 this way
did NP let's just specialize to that so
specialize to 2 C equal a column vector
which means that Q is 1 you only have
one column so then a times B C is versus
a B times C so let's just figure that
out when Q is 1 so n PQ is just n p and
m NQ is just MN where a B is M and P oh
that's a bad one disaster already
multiplying those are potentially two
big matrices multiplying a column vector
so here I've done a matrix
multiplication I never should have done
that this is a matrix vector it gives me
a vector and then this is a matrix
vector so I get nice numbers here but I
get a terrible number for a B and then I
multiply that by C
so that's M PQ m P Q so MP is factoring
out so if I if I write it as n times n
plus P versus this one is M that's
factoring out times M no yeah
what's up here yep sorry what am i doing
yeah
is it P that factors out from this one
okay P times n plus M sorry
anyway the difference is over it again
or or right let me let me do this again
if Q is 1 if I go this way was that's my
final total when Q was 1 and that's this
that's know M factors out times n plus P
whoops just this is oh no n factors out
sorry n factors out times n plus P and
this way was was all these things
both the M and the P factor out okay
thanks times and plus Q and plus Q was
one okay the whole point is we've got
this horrible multiplication of three
big numbers and this only had two big
numbers so this was his orders of
magnitude faster than that and of course
you would have done the calculation that
way you would have multiplied the column
vector by a matrix to get another column
vector and you were to multiply that by
a matrix to get another column vector
where here you crazily multiply two big
matrices together and then got a column
vector so it was the there's there's a
bad move okay thanks so we're off past
the time on this ABC it's just to show
that on a very familiar calculation you
have to do it in the right order and
backpropagation is the right order for
partial derivatives okay thank you and
so bring laptops Friday and look forward
to to professor Ralph give him a good
welcome